serge est très embêté il vient de
recevoir une mise en demeure de ses
voisins les gagnants il affirme être
propriétaire d'une partie de son terrain
sir je n'en reviens pas tout a commencé
qu'il ya plus de 15 ans
serge voulais juste être gentil il a
offert à madame côté savoisienne de
l'époque d'utiliser son stationnement
qu'il n'avait pas besoin
quelques années plus tard les gagne on
achète la maison et continuent
d'utiliser et d'entretenir le
stationnement de serge dont ils se
pensent propriétaire les années passent
et un jour serge achète une voiture veut
récupérer son stationnement et les
problèmes commencent
les gagne on prétendre que le
stationnement leur appartient il invoque
la prescription acquisitive en effet le
code civil permet à une personne de
devenir propriétaire d'un terrain
qu'elle utilise depuis au moins dix ans
de manière paisible continue au vu et au
su de tous et dont elle se considère
propriétaire pour y arriver
les gagnants devront toutefois déposé
une requête au tribunal pour faire
reconnaître leurs droits
la partie n'est pas gagnée pour les
gagnants mais ça s'annonce mal pour
serge le fin mot de l'histoire pour ne
pas perdre terrain gentiment prêté mieux
vous signé une entente avec votre voisin
qui reconnaît qu il vous appartient
question de bien marquer votre
territoire
[Musique]